what's going on guys the boys are back
entourage they're rolling back into
theaters this weekend and that has
inspired us to talk about TV shows that
turn into movies let's introduce the
awesome panel we have to talk about this
subject first he is a critic at large
and the weekend editor for the
nerdist.com Kyle Anderson hello and he's
a good friend of the family actor
comedian hashtag Botanica Mike Carlson
hello hell thank you for having me Kyle
is there a TV show that became a movie
start us off what's one that you like
I'm a big fan of the The Addams Family
movie it's both of them actually but um
that's when we're like I barely knew the
show because it was obviously on to the
sixties yeah and it was kind of just a
silly sitcom and then it became a pretty
dark comedy a like horror filled comedy
and and I think they both hold up pretty
well it might be like the best recast of
all time yeah totally and like of just
people that like totally match the
originals but then do something that's
just as great christina ricci uh cup
shoes born yeah lettuce ransom you flip
out of the grave tonight Oh death let us
be okay
where's Pugsley today hmm well let us
know in the comment section where
Pugsley kiss hashtag where's Pugsley
Mike what's one that you like um I liked
the Mission Impossible movies yeah those
movies have done I think what is a like
unusual thing in that like when we say
Mission Impossible now you probably just
think Tom Cruise you can understand
you're very upset Kittridge you never
seen me very upset other than maybe the
first movie which is sort of referencing
the show a little bit like it just did
its own thing with the name of it and
all anybody who directs it basically
changes it to whatever like a second one
is a John Woo movie the first one is
definitely a Brian De Palma movie and
it's where they're doves in the second
one there's doves on a sec oh man he
does have two guns and motorcycles that
was the most John Woo movie I think of
all time katja dubs I'm gonna throw one
out there might be one of it's
definitely one of my favorites the South
Park movie sure that movie was pretty
soon they were able just curse more they
were able to just be that much more raw
uncle great song and that's like sort of
using the medium of film and the bigger
budget - it's like maximum potential
they used all of that to their advantage
and that's what makes that movies part
of what makes that movie so great I
think what one that's really interesting
to me is is the Naked Gun because that
became a whole series it's based on
police a police story know what was it
call a squad please film the files of
police squad which didn't even last a
full season like it was such a
short-lived show and yet that became a
pretty popular movie franchise maybe
this'll help
still no thang I said touch' you spot me
a 20
how about now I think the one bad thing
that they decided to do is that they
replaced whatever guy was in police
squad with a Jason soon who knew it was
coming no one no one know
[Music]
mic is there another one that we haven't
mentioned yet that you're pretty partial
to well there's a giant one Star Trek
some we'd be more idiots if we didn't
talk about Star Trek let's not be idiots
yes so there's a lot of Star Trek to
talk about the original Star Trek spun
off into movies next-generation spun off
into movies where do you stand on each
of those the original cast probably has
better movies than the next-generation
cast but I'm a little bit more partial
to the next generation cast so I have
maybe more the critic in me says the
original cast has better movies the
child in May says next generation movies
are more fun because I like those
characters but there are some turds in
both bring the ship Oh what does God
need with a starship what about the
newer movies the JJ Abrams movies
compared to the original Star Trek casts
I feel like you can't even call those
based on the show anymore they're based
on memories of the show and they have
yet to Trek the stars which I think is a
big thing in both of those movies
they've had a lot more space battles in
the stars that's true I like the JJ
Abrams movie but what he did was he
pulled Star Trek's head out of its own
ass and for people that really love Star
Trek that's part of it don't we like
yeah like that any that we haven't
mentioned now either good or bad that
you feel can't be left out um I really
like the The Twilight Zone movie from
the eighties that that was me scared me
whatever so scared I was so well done
yeah George Miller of Mad Max George
Miller directed the the last segment
which in the show was William Shatner
going there's someone on the wing um but
in the movie it's it's the John Lithgow
losing his mind because there is a big
giant gremlin on the side of the play
such a refined absolutely
I think the first Brady Bunch movie
deserves some props cuz I think we've
seen a lot of people try to make a movie
that's like tongue-in-cheek and a little
bit meta on like what the era was like
we're trying to poke fun sort of it
whatever era the show started but that
movie sort of pulls it off in in a very
like satisfying way suppose you don't
want to go out with me now huh
of course I do it's not your nose I'm
after okay one last question what's a
movie from a TV show that you want to
see made that hasn't been made what if
they made a lost movie just to try to
explain what the hell happened maybe it
could take place actually on the island
and not in somebody's memory or heaven
or whatever that happened last season
you know what I can get on board with
that and who doesn't need more Hurley in
their life right yeah Mike I'm going I
think this is going to happen but
Adventure Time movies yes like chomping
at the bit for it what TV show do you
want to see turned into a movie let us
know in the comments section below best
answer we're gonna send you a screen
junkies t-shirt I want to thank our
guests for talking about TV shows turn
into movies like champs Kyle Anderson
thanks for coming by Mike Carlson
hashtag Botanica
I'm Hal Rudnick thanks for watch and hit
me up on Twitter bye bye where does
Austin Powers get his fancy I don't know
no yeah baby
all right um so I